Senate Republicans say they have the
votes to repeal the Affordable Care Act
individual mandate the Obamacare law
requires Americans to have health
insurance or pay a penalty the Senate
Finance Committee plans to add the
repeal to its tax reform bill bill that
would help pay for tax cuts and to
cortices on Capitol Hill with the newest
GOP move on health care and - good
morning
good morning this is something of a
surprise move for Senate Republicans who
initially said that tampering with
Obamacare would only complicate the
politics of tax reform but they warmed
up to the idea because repealing the
individual mandate would reduce the
deficit by more than three hundred
billion dollars over ten years and
that's money that they could then plow
back in to middle-class tax cuts the
move however does have some drawbacks
according to the Congressional Budget
Office the number of uninsured Americans
would increase by thirteen million by
the year 2027
last night the Finance Committee
Chairman Orrin Hatch released his new
version of the tax plan indicating that
the child tax credit would now double
from one thousand to two thousand
dollars instead of 1650 and he further
reduced rates slightly for three
middle-class tax brackets this in
response to criticism that the plan
primarily benefits the wealthy House
Speaker Paul Ryan says that the House
version of the plan will not include a
repeal of the individual mandate their
plan is simply too far along and they're
hoping to hold a vote on it tomorrow
Nancy thank you